all right well let's go
yeah speed run ha ha okay 13 37
and we're gonna continue if it ain't
broke don't fix it so we're gonna play
the danish gamut again
[Music]
for the time okay knight f6 so we face
this once
we face this move well that is not a
common move
and it's not a great move it's not a
terrible move either but it it
i mean basically it well my first arrow
is wrong it counter attacks the e4 pawn
um which is reasonable but that knight
is going to start dangling around in my
position and i've explained this at a
couple of points
where the thing with pieces are you can
look at this knight on e4 and you can
say well that's a centralized knight
that's a great night
that's not quite the full truth a piece
can be centralized and still be really
vulnerable
if it's not well supported by other
pieces and pawns and that's clearly the
case here
so a lot of you guys might be looking at
queen e2 or bishop d3 but
that's a little bit reactive queen e2
the knight's gonna drop to c5
and you're gonna regret putting your
queen there because then you're not
gonna be able to get your bishop out
f3 is also tempting but remember what
the problem usually is with playing f3
when they've got a knight on e4 and
that's the check on h4 and i'll
talk about this after the game as well
thank you dubrevich
because then after g3 there's knight
takes two three that's a common pattern
i'm sure
most of you guys have seen so what's the
best approach here the best approach is
to basically ignore the knight for the
time being
and instead to understand what are the
other weaknesses in black position now
this pawn in f7 is actually very weak
it's always weak in the opening but
particularly here
we know that the knight is undefended so
we can combine pressure on this pawn
with attacking the knight and that can
lead to a bunch of forks
how do we actually set that up well a
good way to do that is to play bishop c4
developing the bishop good pressuring f7
good and
we're preparing moves like these which
fork the knight and attack the punt so
it's like a delayed response to the
night i've misled you a little bit i
agree
by pretending that you should do
something immediately with the knight
but you shouldn't do something
immediately
okay queen h4 is is not bad so there's
some tactics here as i said
there's gonna be more tactics involved
in these things he's threatening
checkmate
and the move g3 is very tempting here
why don't we just defend the maid and
attack the queen what's wrong with g3
who can tell me
as a challenging question what's the
problem with just playing g3 and saying
get out of there
you have to look at the whole board here
you have to see what's going on well the
bishop is hanging
right the queen is x-raying the bishop
he can actually take on g3 with a knight
and this queen it it doesn't lose the
rook it doesn't lose the rook
because as for g3 knight takes we can
take with the f pawn our f pawn is still
on f2
but this queen can slide over and pick
up this bishop on c4 which is undefended
that's the key problem black is actually
threatening a discovered attack on the
bishop so
what we need to do is we need to defend
this pawn
and preferably defend this bishop
and after that maybe we can attack the
queen and we can start getting the good
stuff done
so if we play queen f3 that's a good
move
um but he can still move the knight and
perhaps
open fire on this bishop so well let me
think about this first actually
no i actually like queen f3 i'm going to
change my mind here
i i hallucinated for saying yeah let's
play queen f3 i forgot that we're
attacking f7 actually myself
yeah yeah queen f3 is good because we're
attacking f7
and i i was thinking for some reason
that he could like take on f2 maybe he
will
um that would be funny but we're also
attacking f7 that's a big threat that's
not a mate threat but it's almost a may
threat that's good enough to
deter him from any kind of discoveries i
think
yeah nice george thanks for that queenie
two was the move i intended which was
also pretty good
maybe even the best move from a purely
scientific perspective but i like queen
f3
it's going to put him in a very
difficult spot he's got to be very
creative to get out of this now
um it's not a me threat oh de bruy but
you tried to give subs oh did i miss
that
i'm really sorry
um if i did capricorn thank you for the
prime
thank you for the prime well queen f7 he
can move his king to d
this square that i'm that is blinking is
un is accessible
to the king so that's why it's not me
yeah well queen e2 knight f2 i thought
there was g3 that was the line i
calculated
like queen e4 there it's complicated or
or
joe there's maybe knight f3 after knight
takes after attacking the queen
i think that might be good for white
it's actually there he goes dubrovich
with a five thank you so much man i
really appreciate it
you're the man i've seen you in the bras
appreciate the subs
that's awesome five gifts you know d5 is
weird he's
he seems to be defending against stuff
but he's just giving the pawn i mean
just
thank you right she go another five subs
oh my land's damn girl
look at this go another five for me
chico
tons of support today i really
appreciate that and sweet messages to
boot and
and 500 bits from m4 thank you so much
man i appreciate oh my lens another five
from rpm here we go
the 12 am hype has begun
five more from rpm and five more from
ann
hoags oh my god and this is crazy now
it's crazy
well thank you guys this is amazing
oh my god curious chimpanzee jumping in
another five
this is insane bishop e6 all right what
else is insane is we're taking all of
his pieces
bishop e6 is um he's defending against
the
the threat of f7 but he's forgetting
that he's not seeing the bigger picture
here
now we can take on vsan but i mean let's
play rashford russian school
maybe the best move is to take on b-side
i don't want to deal with this knight
anymore i'm tired of this night being
here and causing troubles
let's just take the free night instead
maybe we'll only win a night
but at least we won't have to worry
about various threats right
that's always a judgment call you have
to make is you have to be able to say i
think maybe this is going to be the best
move but
let me do something that's also good and
it's going to be more practical if that
makes sense
okay so bishop g4
indeed did mutual now where should we
put our queen there's many good squares
we can put it on g3 and basically force
the queen train
fair but the best square is to
understand that we're also attacking b7
with the bishop so if we where would we
want to reposition our queen
so that this queen participates in the
pressure on b7 you should go with a
10 with a thousander thank you yeah
let's slide it over here and now our
pressure on this pawn has become
unbearable
yeah just like the opera game exactly
what i was thinking about
now he should probably go here and
counter-attack this yeah he does
but now it is finally time for a move
that we wanted to play for a while
now that his knight is gone and now that
the pressure is not as spicy
some of you i think are maybe seeing
this that is not a fork
i mean it is a fork it's not a
particularly good one
because he can bring his knight out and
defend the bishop at the same time
but instead we can just go g3 get out of
here finally it's our time to play this
move
then we can start gorging on
black's queen side and when is
this jiggle finger the tier one
all right we've got some funny names
today yes um
so yeah let's
let's see where he goes with this queen
but there's nothing that he can do
because f6 and tipsy tipsy flipper thank
you for the tier one
yeah well queen we need seven okay so
now we need to be a little bit careful
here
we need to be a little bit careful here
what should we take this with
it doesn't actually matter what we take
it with we can take it with either piece
i like taking this pawn of the bishop
because
as i've said before there's this rule
that you generally
when you have two pieces that you can do
something with
you usually want to assign it to the
piece of smaller value
which is a little bit paradoxical you
might think well i want to do with a
queen it's going to be more reliable
um you know it's going to be more
reliable it's like when i was little and
i would
i would hear the adults ordering a steak
like i'd always want it well done
because or my brother was like because
like why would you not have it well done
it's like the best thing i want the best
steak i don't want a medium
or like my my dad would be like medium
well why are you ordering media well
like
i wanted to be to be good um
but the thing is when you take with a
piece of smaller value you leave the
piece of bigger value
to do other important stuff so here the
bishop is perfectly capable of dealing
with this rook the rook's not going here
the queen is going to be on b3 for the
time being
and we don't know how it is going to be
used and already we have a very good use
for this queen
and that's not to put it on e3 and
blunder it but what should we put on e3
and how does the queen figure in this
uh mosaic of rolls that we've assigned
to our pieces thank you
for the tier one
and thank you ryan kl
yeah i know you played like a beast no
we don't have to play king f1 on that
although that's fine but just bishop e3
blocks the check and encourages trades
and that's for perfectly good
um
[Applause]
oh my god oh crap i got it
oh my god no i only now just got it
i i was thinking the other day about
like will there ever be someone who
buries some sort of vile name
so d so deep that like i won't be able
to spot it at all
like it'll just catch me by surprise and
i guess the answer to it is yes
um so
oh my god um because the sack
sack mic you know and you know what the
last thing is that's pretty obvious
for me one shame on you but um
[Laughter]
these things are easy to miss okay
so what should we do here uh he's
i mean people just dedicate their time
to this stuff like i'm gonna make a
twitch name like this and i'm so happy
with myself
yeah queen c3 of course it encourages
the queen trade
and it also and it also attacks the
bishop
it also it also attacks the bishop with
two pieces so
um sorry
uh yeah bishop d4 we just take that we
can't take it with the bishop because
we're pinned
but we can take it with the queen thank
you very much
um and
yeah um
yeah and now the game is over because
now he's down two pieces already and
he's losing a rook and
he's losing another knight and his queen
yeah he's starting to drop a lot of
pieces here
yes i think this one's over yeah we're
taking his queen next
and we're gonna have enough material
here to feed a village
for eight years
yeah that's true no losing your queen is
one of the most crushing feelings it's
there's a
there's a sense of of turman uh just
the game is okay he we need to watch the
square and this is one
great example of just like not not
um being too mirthful about being up
interiors like he can go bishop g4
and you can pre-move whatever like some
random move
and you get checkmated it takes so
little pieces to actually deliver
checkmate we don't stop to think about
that
we actually as i say as i just talk up a
storm and i'm
not barely paying attention to what he's
doing or this was even much this was
much stronger it would have won both of
his
both of his remaining works but um
yeah this is just i'm not really
commenting on this because we're taking
all of his pieces just
sequentially um which is something that
we all
are kind of good at
yeah sacking the queen is an
unparalleled feeling
in chess no matter how beautiful other
combinations are there's a
there's a soft spot that is reserved in
every player's heart i think for the
queen sacrifice
okay so i'm gonna make a i'm gonna make
a move that looks bad but i want you
guys to tell me why it's good
have i just blundered my knight
have i i mean not that i couldn't not i
could afford that and
i could afford even blundering my rook
and then my queen and even my other rook
but no i can actually skewer him and win
the bishop back
i'm not gonna or queen f6 nicely nice
catch i i miss that move
we haven't even moved our oaks we
probably will we're gonna let's see if i
can castle with me
i'm gonna see if i can actually set this
up
so i cancel with mate let me see
if i can set this up so i can cast let
me think about how to get this done
first of all
where do i need my pieces well
i need i need this i i need this rook in
and then i'm gonna castle long
i i don't want to rub it in and we're
gonna cut him off now so the king has to
eventually go back
yes now we're going to use this rook to
cordon him off the other way no no
please don't go here just move your
pawns so i can
no get back okay this is this is
unnecessary i'm just going to mate him
i don't know why i'm fixated on on
castling with i'm just going to castle
and then checkmate
whoa jmj with 25 damn
oh my lens that's crazy 25
and dunlop's on top of it
yeah okay fine i'm just gonna castle i i
mean i i i don't think it's worth the
effort
it's epic but it's not it's not that
epic i think it's way overrated
um we're going to castle thank you so
much jim jim this is crazy explosion of
subs today
as always and then we're going to slide
the rook in and that's going to be
checkmate
all right this is the moment which is
most
uh hardest to understand i think because
you you want to attack the knight and
that's that's it's
attacking the night itself is not the
mistake the mistake there's no good way
to attack it
because right now the knight doesn't
escape to c5 so you're not trying to
trap the knight
you're not going to trap the knight
that's something you should dispense
with immediately
you should dispense with that fiction
that that we don't know what we're doing
he knows exactly what he's doing and um
that's why moves like f3 while good in
principle are misplaced because
there's a sense in which you're trying
to trap the knight but here i go queen
h4 check
g3 knight g3 hg3 and i'm sure
everybody's seen this pattern before
yeah so this is this is this is very bad
um and if you play bishop well if you
play queen e2 then i'm going to drop the
knight back
and you're going to have a hard time
defending developing this bishop this
isn't this isn't terrible but it's not
great
but bishop c4 is great because it sets
up better moves it sets up queen d5 it
sets up queen f3
so you have to exercise restraint when
it comes to pieces if you have a good
card
um you know there's card games we have
to play your cards you have to hold your
cards
close to your chest sometimes and when
you play them they're going to be a lot
stronger than if you rush them
okay we can we can turn off subs only
for the next five the last five minutes
of the stream
quinn h4 and now queen f3
so again if we go g3 here and we say
well great
we're attacking the queen get out of
here black goes knight takes g3
and actually if we think hard about it
there's something even
better than taking the bishop which is
amazing welcome guys and sorry
we had to go subs only but that
discussion that we had it was it was
getting a little bit
i wouldn't say out of control but i mean
i needed a little bit of a of a peaceful
moment i know everybody understands
um and it's remember that when we go sub
only it's like
it's never personal and i know that it
can be it's very easy to perceive it
that way like oh
he's like angry at me it's not
anger at anybody in particular it's just
it's the only tool i understand it's a
rough tool but it's the only tool i have
at my disposal to
make things go a little bit more calmly
um
and so thanks yeah i appreciate it
thanks for the understanding
okay what is white's what is black's
better move here what
what else can black do other than queen
take c4
thank you m4 i appreciate it why um
what what what does black have other
than queen take c4
oh wait wait no what am i what am i
saying sorry i meant to say
f takes g3 after f takes g3 i meant
yeah queen e4 check yeah queen e4 check
is what i meant
and actually black can pick off the
exchange it's not that simple but
that's basically the bottom line uh
so for that reason we go queen f3 we
create a bigger thread equal or stronger
threat
and after d5 bishop i mean d5 is where
he collapses
black i think has only one defense here
no he's got to play knight g5 that's his
only move because
he defends the pawnee attack and if we
take the knight and say ah well now i'm
going to take on f7
no but now he swings over and takes the
other bishop
um yeah oh absolutely i'll be happy to
do it next time and michiko gifting to
tom flynn
thank you again so the queen is in a bad
spot that's that's actually the point
that's why i said it's not that simple
but it's not in bad enough of a spot
where he can't get out
so after knight g5 here i would have
just dropped the queen to e2
and defended the bishop and aharian
gifting us up to grog
and then white can develop the pieces
this knight is very awkward black's made
a lot of moves with the same b so
white's better but it's not winning
um well the thing is demon it's a double
edged sword because this knight is both
bad and good at the same time
it's good because it's attacking the
pawn so queen e2
is a bit risky that's what i wanted to
play but it's a bit risky because of
this move
and i was discussing this with joe joe
bruin
and uh this is actually very unclear
because if you take the knight
and the queen slides over from the
bishop and
if um if you try to chase the queen away
then it's got all these squares where it
can attack other pieces so it's very
unclear
so queen f3 circumvents this because
this is a devastating move and black's
position collapses here
okay um so
d5 is played and after bishop d5
everything goes downhill for him
i think at this point black has only one
way to avoid further material losses and
that's probably to play f5
which kills two birds with one stone
defends the knight and it defends the
pawn
and at this point i can take another
pawn
and we trade and it looks like black uh
rook is getting trapped but if you've
seen morphe against duke of brunswick
what's up logic
very good to see you and we've got
absolute um we've got absolute royalty
in in in the house
um so black actually has two
alternatives here there's queen
e4 check and there's queen b4 check
and both of those moves force a queen
trade right because it's whoops that is
not a move the force is a queen trait
this is a move that forces a queen trade
and um you know the queen is protected
so
queen odds more than happy to
maybe it's an encore um but you're gonna
beat the crap out of me and you know
you're
gonna make you look bad and well maybe
that's not i think it's about time for
that anyway
so
yeah six more like 60 but um
i wouldn't play yourself down i mean i i
think yeah but queenons would be
interesting for sure
shush tommy yeah and the other move here
is queen b4 check by the way to
def exactly the same mechanism you get
the bishop now white is still up two
pawns here this is still good for white
and um yeah and and this is just fine
uh but but black can play the bottom
line is it's only only two pawns so
black can play on and that's something
you have to do if you're on the black
side of this for example you have to
mitigate
you have to try to do damage control you
can't just put your head down just go
into the tunnel just drop all of your
pieces
that's kind of what he did here he just
lost
he lost hope in this game i think and um
that's very easy to do in these
situations but there's usually going to
be a middle ground where you can
basically
limit the damages um where you can
basically
limit the damage there's usually gonna
be
some resource um
there's usually some resource that
allows you to
you know to to keep the game going even
if it looks like everything is
collapsing so after
bishop b6 bishop b4 it's essentially all
over him of a piece
then i'm up another one and everything
is just
um everything is just over here
yeah queen c3 and the rest is the rest
is very straightforward so we don't have
to um
we don't have to really look at it in
detail
okay is it necessary to castle and the
queens are off the board not
necessarily i mean it can be a good idea
just independently to bring the rooks
into the game but
from a king safety perspective only if
your king is in danger which it
sometimes is when the queens are off the
board
alright this is absolute epicness on a
large scale
[Music]